girl you better come over here with this
look good how are you you look gorgeous
I mean what a huge night for you you're
pulling double duty tonight you're
performing and hosting and let's talk
about hosting first because how's it
feel to be sharing the stage with some
bad dreams coming true we have blood
yeah we have out of sadly we have Roslin
who's like they've all you know I mean
you look at their careers and everything
they've accomplished and then you got me
and my girl Leslie nowhere Young is in
the game we got a nice resume too but
we're still learning and that chemistry
is just so awesome I mean we've had so
much fun in the last couple days
preparing talking about outfit changes
hair makeup ideas and Leslie are
performing we're gonna have a great time
I was talking to your girl Leslie about
how cool it is that you guys get to
share in this entire experience not even
tonight but the whole thing together
what you like to share with your homey I
mean could you ask for in this career I
feel like you know it's so easy as an
artist to feel lonely although you're on
stage in front of thousands of people
it's like you always go back to your
lonely hotel room and you're always like
then wouldn't it be nice if there's
somebody in this world who understood
what I was going through and Leslie and
I I mean I feel like have always felt
that we were cut from the same cloth you
know speaking from like a personal side
of things our perspectives on life and
family and then you look at our careers
and it's just it's awesome like I
couldn't like I said she's like one of
my greatest fans and like I told her I'm
gonna tell you the same thing you guys
are the future of Latin music alright
let's talk about fashion real quick cuz
you're killing the game don't don't tell
the producers this all right well would
you get in trouble but I have so many
like outfit options and I still haven't
decided and like I'm trying to make like
- man outfit changes happen today
because I'm trying to make the most out
of it you know you have them on lockdown
you're rated yeah
how many outfit changes do you think I'm
pushing for like including my
performance outfit and this red carpet
outfit like eight
I got standard rice for sure for you
hosting duties absolutely it real quick
so how you getting in the zone cuz I do
get nervous of this kind of stuff like
you have to take a shot of tequila
always uh-huh I mean that's just ritual
but I feel like there is a part of me
that doesn't you know I get butterflies
I get excited but I also feel like
there's always this couple seconds right
before you walk onstage where you think
to yourself what the hell am I doing
here how did I get here we belong here
right but it's like it without that
feeling I almost feel like you're like
you might as well quit you have to have
that you know what I mean so it's
awesome keep the fire alive girl have
fun tonight